moins de 10 ans après son entrée en
politique comme conseiller municipal
d'opposition à trappe otman nasrou est
désormais le leader de la droite
ivlinoise il a été élu président de la
fédération départementale des
républicains celui qui est également
vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France a recueilli 75 % des voix
au terme de ce scrutin interne qui s'est
tenu les 26 et 27 novembre l'élection a
rassemblé 3000 adhérents je suis
agréablement surpris par le score et je
suis très honoré les militants ont
choisi une ligne claire celle d'une
droite qui s'assume et je ne dévirai pas
du Cap proche de Valérie pcrè Hotman
nasrou faisait face à Philippe benasaya
pour cette élection l'ex-maire de
boisarcy et ancien député récolte
environ 25 % des suffrages le nouveau
président des républicains des evelines
souhaite néanmoins rassembler et
travailler avec son adversaire au
renouveau de la droite je suis prêt à
travailler avec tous ceux qui le
voudront y compris bien sûr Philippe
benasaya car on ne peut plus se payer le
luxe de s'offrir des divisions Hotman
nasrou succède à Pierre Bédier qui a
passé près de 20 ans à la tête des
fédérations département du RPR de l'UMP
puis des LR sa première mission préparer
la campagne des élections européennes
programmé l'an prochain dans un
territoire des ivelines où les
républicains perdent du terrain le
département compte encore de nombreux ma
LR mais plus aucun député la Fédération
a perdu en 5 ans environ 600 adhérents